good afternoon welcome to ee380 the
stanford electrical engineering computer
systems colloquium
which meets every wednesday
our speaker today is dick seitz
who has a long
a long and uh pretty illustrious history
in the uh in the business
and he is uh talking about uh some of
the work that he's reported in his uh
understanding software dynamics his
recent book
probably the
uh the most significant book of the year
i think
um it's a great uh it's a great read uh
i'm not finished with it but i'm i'm
making considerable progress every night
um in any case uh
it's going to tell us about what it's
like making the invisible web
invisible making the invisible visible
and this is the problem of how do you
see what a complex computer system is
really doing
and uh thank you for
coming up and uh
participating as a speaker
and um just a little word of
advertisement
we're coming up at the end of the
quarter
and beginning the next quarter
and there are going to be 10 more
lectures in the
computer systems lab
series of colloquia
and
you should
sign up on the website
ee380.stanford.edu
and get our announcements and uh
come and see some of the more
interesting things that are going on
anyhow dick it's um
it's all yours thank you very much i'm
uh
into very brief introductions now so
you'll have to explain yourself
take care bye-bye
all right
thank you dennis and uh welcome everyone
i'm i'm sort of flat talking to screens
and with two screens in front of me a
particularly flat one i'm looking at the
wrong screen
so my wife had this brilliant suggestion
that i have pasted a picture of our son
next to the camera and i will speak to
him for the next 45 minutes
so the i'm going to talk about making
the visible visible
observing complex software dynamics i've
been interested uh
basically forever in software
performance and understanding why things
are slow
and it's hard to understand for very
complex software why it's slow until you
can actually observe what it's doing
which when it's slow is always not a
match to the picture in our heads as
programmers we think of things in very
simple ways and we tend to ignore
page faults and interrupts and things
that we can't quite
imagine well and
it takes a long time to
realize that the fictional head doesn't
match reality and how it doesn't match
reality and therefore what's wrong and
what to be sped up
so
if i had my cursor in the right place i
could change slides here we go so i'm
going to tell you what complex of what i
mean by complex software dynamics and
then go through the only seven reasons
that code can be slow when it normally
runs at a pretty decent speed the
intended speed
and then
now and then doing transactions or
something or database lookups or
analyzing
video frames 30 times a second while a
car is going down the road at 80 miles
an hour there's only seven things that
can make it go slowly now and then so
i'll go through each of those and then a
summary at the end
so
here's a picture of simple software this
is just a timeline running on one cpu
for a few seconds
the
program starts over here on the edge it
runs solid cpu bound for a few seconds
and it stops it has a few loops that are
marked here
this is what i mean by complex software
this is uh
[Music]
a couple milliseconds of the chrome
browser running on four cpus so on the
y-axis there's four cpu co3c
three
on the x-axis there's a couple
milliseconds of time
and at each each instant and time at
each nanosecond the diagram shows what's
executing on that cpu core
so the black lines are idle
the sine wave will get back to it a
little bit
the high colored boxes are operating
system code kernel code
and the half height color boxes are user
mode code
and in this case i've labeled all of the
the first instance of each user mode
thread so there's seven different
threads running here
and the arcs are showing
that this system call in this thread
woke up that thread and it ran here this
system call woke up that thread and it
didn't run for a long time but sometimes
that's the problem we want to look at
so this includes everything all
interrupts all system calls all page
faults all transitions between user node
and kernel mode
are what i trace and then the
post-processing turns those transitions
which is a very small amount of
information into the diagrams of
everything that's going on
with no uh
no nanosecond lost
so i'm focused on time sensitive
application code so user code i'm not
interested in
the operating system per se i'm
interested in
when the operating system slows down
what my program is doing my program is a
user mode thing
i'm interested in code that's already
been debugged it has good design has
good algorithms it's normally runs as
desired with good performance but has
unexpected sporadic
serious delays
sometimes only delays that occur in a
production environment that occur in
testing environments
and those are the uh hard things that a
lot of people sort of live with but i
have spent
the last 15 years or more
trying to understand what's really going
on and they're then finding things that
are oh well that's screwed up and it
takes 20 minutes to fix
so when you have repetitive code that's
doing individual transactions whatever
that only occasionally runs slowly
there's just three things you can make
it run slowly either you're executing
more code in the slow cases than in the
normal cases
or you're executing the same code but
you're executing it more slowly for some
reason
or you're not executing you're waiting
for something
and you'll find that i
in the next uh
15 minutes or so we'll
complain about
observation tools that that uh totally
ignore the not executing and therefore
can't tell you why you're waiting and
there's only five things to wait for
there's five uh five resources
cpu
memory disk for ssd network
and locks software critical sections so
the first four are hardware resources
and last one is software resource
in
real production systems there's nothing
else you end up waiting on
and as an industry we generally have
very poor tools or observing what's
really happening and particularly in
time-sensitive production code where
a tool that slows everything down by 10
is useless cannot cannot be used in a
production
data center or inside of a an airplane
or whatever
inside of the database even the 10
slowdown is is generally
terrible
so i'm going to talk about uh the system
called kutrace kernel user tracing
the book talks about it a lot and the
code there's a reference on the slide at
the end the code is all open sourced on
github
it's a small set of linux kernel batches
that record every transition between
user mode and kernel mode
and each of those transitions is
recorded in just four bytes a 20-bit
timestamp and a 12-bit which transition
what happened which event and that's all
and i just write those in memory as as
fast as they occur
in reserved kernel ram
the overhead for doing that is less than
one percent in a busy production data
center environment
with 200 000 transitions per second per
core
the overhead is less than one percent
and it's much much less than that in
simple environments then everything else
and all of the diagrams i'm going to
show you come from post-processing the
raw traces that just have
these very simple very compact
transitions
so
visibility
um until you trace when code is running
all the execution time of all the
threads on all the cores is captured you
know not just my program but all the
other surrounding programs not just user
code but the
operating system itself
because those are the sources of
interference and if you don't look at
them it's like if you can't see them
it's like looking for the
lost car keys under the lamp post
because the light's good there even
though you drop them
two blocks over
for things that are not running
you have a thread that's running and it
stops running it doesn't spontaneously
stop there's a reason and when later it
restarts it doesn't spontaneously
restart there's a reason
so i'm going to ask questions now that
we have a few people just uh unmute and
give you to word answer and mute again
what are some of the reasons that
running threads stop and start again
pick one
system calls
the web
system called
system called
yes system calls
oh system calls
switching right
the uh
yeah if a thread does the system call
and the system call returns to that
thread um it doesn't stop running you do
a system call that then blocks and uh
then you go through the schedule and
goes to some other thread right
it's end of time slots
end of time slot again you end up going
to get some timer internet and it goes
off to the scheduler and changes yeah so
there's a bunch of those and if you
don't if you can't see what it's doing
it's hard to figure out which things are
making your threads that you want to be
executing
not execute
so
the way i design ku trace the reason for
not executing is always in the trace
there's
a thread that's running along in user
mode can't spontaneously stop executing
without going to the operating system
there's no user mode stop executing
instruction
and because we get the transition into a
particular operating system uh routine
you get to see why it stopped and then
later you get to see what it stops and
never water
so if you're running along
can you block inside of a cis reed or
something
you get that's in the trace later if
some thread wakes us up again
it's a
inside of a system call that does the
wake up i capture the wake up
and then draw the arcs and then
eventually a scheduler runs and
redispatches the thing to block and
that's in the trace
there's nothing else
that can make things start or stop
that's missing from the trace
so i'm going to go through now in a
series of seven things and you mentioned
the water
of the the seven reasons that things
connect can execute slowly or not
execute at all in each each sequence
i'll show a black box of the execution
lines of some sample programs
and then the detailed observations of
what's really going on and then not talk
about the new causes
so we talked about executing too much
code so here's a sample program that's
doing some transactions and there's two
short ones two more short ones and in
the middle there's one that's 16 times
longer
so
this is assuming that for most
transaction systems database systems
whatever that somebody's keeping track
of when something starts and when it
stops when it starts when it stops but
that's all we have
if we look more carefully
at in this case keeping on cpu zero we
can see that
the first transaction's
starting to stop started stop this one
somehow takes longer there's it's just
all solid execution time
if we do a pc sampling profile of this
sort of thing the profile looks like
this about half the time is spent in
some routine called checksum in the
sample program about a third of the time
is spent in them copy
about 12 in something called decrypting
checksum and then the other couple
percenters and a few other things
including
in this profiler samples from the
operating system itself
and occasionally in fact with ku trace
running samples of the ku trace code
itself if it happens to be the thing
that's executing just when a timer
interrupt comes in
so where in that profile
is the explanation of why this is 16
times longer
it's not there it's the wrong tool
pc samples are useless
for distinguishing
the short transactions on the long ones
all
the profiling does is it adds up lots of
samples
and it so it smashes together all of the
good cases with the bad case uh
reducing the signal to the
noise ratio of the bad cases down to
almost nothing
so instead if we take the same pc
samples but record them
sequentially in a trace say this
happened and then this happened and then
this happened
correlated with all the other stuff
that's going on time stamp with the same
time base we get to see ah in this
particular sample program
this timer interrupt sample
found that this code was running the
routine called decrypting checksum and
so was that one and so was that one and
so was that one and the sample out here
was in a routine called checksum or
regular checksum and in fact across the
whole trace of the sample program what
we found
is that the decrypting checksum is only
run in the long transactions
and that the regular checksum and them
copying things samples are are
scattered across the other transactions
so in fact what's going on is the long
transaction
is executing different code extra code
too much code
in decrypting checksum which the
programmer thought the programmer knew
was just as fast as the regular checksum
but of course it isn't at 16 dives
slower and now we can see it and now you
know what to go fix
but your profile will never tell you
so to summarize executing too much code
too much code comes from branching you
have some if statement that you that
doesn't normally happen and then in this
location it does happen and there's a
whole much more code executed
or
calls that you didn't expect to happen
or call backs
and what we
think i want you to go away remembering
is that profiles merge together lots of
fast cases with the slow cases hiding
what's different about the slow ones
therefore useless traces are reveal
what's different
so i'm going to execute it too slowly um
are there any questions on the uh
executing too much code
yes i have a
comment i mean because you now you're
talking about the profiler by periodic
interrupts but there are some other ways
like for example on i'm not sure if
you're aware about the cortex-m
architecture
that they have
they can sample the pc every 32-bit
clocks
of
cpu is very dense no no it is very dense
very dense but but if the profile
samples are simply added up and counted
that they can't tell you they don't
correlate with here's where the slow
action was and here's where the fast
action actually
it is because at every sample they send
a full pc so you know exactly where you
are and that that's
it means that this similar way what what
you're saying but anyway that's just a
note so with the with the sort of proper
hardware support you may have a very
dense sampling which it is very nice
every 64
clock cycles you can have a full pc you
you can build
what you're saying is they actually are
recording a trace of all of the samples
they're not just adding they're not just
counting them of course yes yes
okay then it's a trace
it's a full trace right right anyway
that's just because i just for
information coming from a high-end
debug and trace tools sure that's
right
we did the same thing in the alpha chips
in 1992 of uh every 64k cycles we could
generate an interrupt and do a pc sample
it doesn't matter whether it's high
density or low density samples what
matters is you keep them all and
correlate them with what else is
happening instead of just counting them
exactly right
right
let me go on to executing too slowly
so here's an example of a simple program
um it's a benchmark
and we run it twice and the second time
it's 40 percent slower in the first time
then all we know is you know i started
here and ran there and got to print
papers about how fast it is
but there's no information about why the
second one is 40 slower
so if we trace it this is actually a
very old whetstone benchmark
and it starts up and it runs and it has
a bunch of modules module two module
three uh that are tight loops uh
nominally measuring floating point
performance from 1960s
here's the second run
it simply takes a whole lot longer you
can see that a few of the loops like m2
don't take any more time and some of the
loops like
m11 get a lot longer
we can't tell yet from just this amount
of information
why the other ones are longer but if
something executes
at a at the expected speed and then the
identical code
executes more slowly
on some other run
the only thing
going on is there's some kind of
interference from other programs
the interference can come from shared
hardware resources you know there's some
other program uh beating the cache to
death or main memory or their shared
software critical sections the
interference comes from what else is
running
so observation tools that only look at
one program can never tell you what's
going on if you're executing too slowly
so instead with the ku trace we're
looking at all the cores all of the
processes all of the time we get to see
what else is going on in this case
it's a
dummy uh floating point hog program that
runs for
20 milliseconds or so
and
200 milliseconds and then stops for
about 200 then runs again this pops um
this is a useful technique for seeing
what what the program you're worried
about is sensitive to
so if we look in more detail at a little
bit of this
oh first i'm going to show you a little
speedometers of instructions for cycle
so part of the tracing is at every
transition i record not only a time
stamp but the number of instructions
that have been retired
and then in the next transition i record
the time stamp and number instructions
and then i subtract and divide and get
instructions per cycle
and a little speedometer pointing off to
to the left is showing less than an
eighth of an instruction per cycle in
other words more than eight cycles per
instruction
um diagonally up to the left is half the
cycle this is one cycle it's two cycles
or four cycles it's a
sort of a logarithmic scale
so if we look at the module 11 loop when
it's running all by itself it's running
at about one and a quarter instructions
per cycle
when this floating point hog starts up
suddenly it drops by a factor of three
and it's now running at about three
eighths of an instruction per cycle
and then when the hog stops picks up
again and these are these are a few
microsecond time scale uh
line ranges
and the module 9 loop over here when
it's running at full speed with no
interference it's running about three
and a half
instructions per cycle and when there's
interference it drops down to about two
and a half so it's about 40 percent
slower
so from
the
trace with the instructions for cycle
over all of the little bitty pieces you
can see exactly that module 2 doesn't
slow down
the reason is it doesn't do any floating
point instructions
it's a it's a bogus benchmark
and you can see that module 11 does lots
of floating point divides
and slows down more than the other the
other ones
so you get to see exactly the
interference and of course
if you have interference
you either need to fix your program so
it's less sensitive with interference or
you need to fix the other program so it
doesn't interfere as much or you need to
run them separately
but once you know what the interference
mechanism is you can decide what to do
about it and usually
that decision is pretty simple
so executing too slowly in summary comes
from other threads other programs the
operating system itself interfering with
our program or it can also come i
haven't talked about it here
from
running on a cpu where the clock
frequency has been reduced dramatically
to save power
this this leads to
programs that run more slowly
on nearly idle machines than running on
really busy machines
because
they're running five times slowly at
like 800 megahertz instead of
uh
3.9
gigahertz
can also run slowly due to slow exits
from power statement that
chips go into power saving to reduce the
clocks and reduce the the
voltage levels and reduce the epoxy
reduce the voltage levels
coming out of that like intel deep c6
state can take 30 microseconds
and if you have
a
dynamics
perhaps between bouncing back and forth
between threads you can keep paying that
30 microseconds many times in a row very
close together and it's a real slowdown
so go away with the idea that
microsecond scale instruction cycle
reveals the interference between tasks
looking at instructions for cycle over
two seconds tells you nothing looking at
it over a millisecond or so doesn't tell
you very much but looking at it over
just these microsecond scale uh
execution intervals at every interval
tells you a lot
so waiting for something
so could you go to the previous slide
please
uh so here uh you i i agree that you
could find the interference between
tasks but
in in the example you should you
mentioned that it was the floating the
floating divide unit so
uh it does
does the tractor do the trackers help in
identifying that as well or
i mean or do you have to manually look
at the two programs and infer that hey
maybe it's this unique
oh
well first these are uh
two cpu cores that are hyper threaded
that's why there's interference between
them if this program are running on the
different core in this uh machine
i just happen to know that the
interference is from floating point
divides but usually if you're interested
in performance
uh slow downs it may not matter what the
actual interference mechanism is it's
just that ah when that runs this goes
slowly and so what are we going to do
about it sometimes it does matter but
there's only
three high-level choices
the interference is is with is at memory
or it's uh
shared functional units that aren't
fully pipelined hence floating point
divide
or
i forgot the third one at the moment
anyway it says oh oh it's a branch
misprediction
if something is is causing
branch misprediction uh you can
slow down a lot
yeah thank you does that answer your
question
yeah it does yeah
okay or cash swipe right kind of if the
cash is like being constantly you know
swiped away that's also could happen you
you have to re recache data right
again yeah
for instance when you go off to the
operating system
on a page fault and it does a uh a copy
on write it it copies 4k from a
read-only page to a newly allocated
rewrite page
that 4k copy can fill up um
and display stuff and then when you come
back what you see is you run more slowly
right after page fault and that's a
direct form of interference from the
operating system not from other programs
and we see those in traces i'm not sure
if i have an example oh i do have an
example of one
actually i can show you that now
okay so unfortunately i don't get any
feedback of what you all see
so i'll start over quickly
and this is hello world running on four
cpus
and
i started it over ssh so the ssh demon
here is getting an interrupt uh
a
network interrupt this is the soft
interrupt handler bottom half for rx it
wakes up this other thread k worker
which wakes up
bash the
operating system shell
which does a clone call
which makes a copy of itself
ash with a different num different
process number which does an execute c
which brings in hello world
and starts to execute it these are
markers i put in at the very first line
of hello world of the very last line and
we can see that hello world itself
runs for
154 microseconds
and if you zoom way in
i include at the edges
what the approximate overhead is okay
you trace itself so you can tell if you
have a whole lot of really really close
together things whether the overhead is
too much
if we turn on the instructions per cycle
on all these little pieces
what you can see sometimes
this is probably a bad example but you
can see
if the user code is running quickly and
then your page fault page fault page
fault
actually you can see here
the page fault code here runs slowly
a little faster a little faster a little
faster a little faster this is the page
fault code
bam bam bam bam bam
putting its own stuff into the cache
and then when that sequence finishes if
the user code had been had a lot of
stuff in the cache that got displaced by
these page faults the user code would
run slowly out here in this particular
case the user code is running slowly
well there's our name faster and then
after the page faults
it's running slower
so that's the kind of interference you
can see from across the operating system
okay so we're off waiting for something
so when you're waiting for something it
means it's not executing so profiles
that sample pcs aren't going to tell you
anything
um and instead
uh
you get to see what it is you're waiting
for
so here's an example of waiting for the
cpu we have three threads in the sample
this other sample program running over
here the fourth thread gets a software
lock and these three block
the fourth thread frees up the software
lock
two of the three start and the third one
doesn't start for a long time in fact
this is uh two milliseconds
later the question is why is that guy
waiting
and of course from the
time stamps or profiles or whatever you
can't tell
if we look at
the ku traces now it's sorted by process
id instead of by cpu number
here's the three processes running
here's the fourth one
there's a pink line here that shows that
it's holding a lock and the color of the
line says pixlr
and
in the html shift clicking on the line
tells you by name which lock
and then at the end this wakes up this
freezer lock and wakes up the other
threads except one wake up takes a long
time
i'm going to look at what's really going
on there
at this point
the fourth thread first does a write
it's a debugging write and that right
wakes up
a process called gmain
which is the gnome display process which
in turn is going to wake up the ssh
process
uh not shown here because i was running
this log in and so
after that right
the thread that was holding the lock
sees that when it frees the lock that
there are other waiters and it does a
futex system call here and wakes up the
other three waiters
[Music]
at that moment there are five threads
and only four cpus there's the three
threads that are getting woken up
there's the g main thread which wasn't
in the picture in my head
and there's the thread doing the right
that's about to finish but it's not yet
finished
and then there's a scheduler screw up
that
when this cpu gets free a little bit off
the to the right here
the linux scheduler doesn't run the
waiting thread
it doesn't run it until there's a timer
interrupt way out here
and it looks around and says oh there's
something i can run meanwhile in here
there's a couple milliseconds of
uh two cpus doing nothing
while the third while this while my
third thread waits
so there's really a heisenberg here
if you take out the debugging right
there's no fifth thread problem goes
away if the debugging right goes to a
local disk instead of uh over the
network via the ssh or whatever there's
no fifth thread
and there's no screw up if the scheduler
didn't have the screw up you could have
the right and the extra thread and there
would be a very tiny performance bug
that you wouldn't care about so since
combination of a debug ride and ssh
access and the scheduler
it gives you a bug
and so the good news is that
ku trace has such low overhead that it
doesn't disturb highs and bugs
they're still there and you can see what
they're doing
so to summarize waiting for cpus you can
wait for cpus because they're all busy
you can wait because the scheduler has
too strong affinity
for where the task for where task last
ran it won't move it to another course
and they're not
the time constant here because you're
trying to go back to warm cache is only
about 50 microseconds
while the
linux scheduler default for giving up
and moving
a task to a different uh
a different core is 12 milliseconds
uh there's also delays from coming down
to power saving states and the complex
interactions
let's see so go away the idea that wake
up events tell us what a threat was
waiting for
the um
in this case
due to the scheduler screw up it was
waiting for
time to have passed it's the timer
interrupt that wakes it up
so
reading for memory
it's another little sample program this
one is
a
parent task that
uses p threads and clones
the child task
he said the child test takes a long time
to start and we don't know why
if you look at what's going on this is
the parent task it's actually doing a
clone call here it's another one it's
cloning four children
the first one turns out to be the one
we're looking at
uh and then it's cloned as four children
and stops running
this child that we're looking at starts
running here
immediately takes a page fault because
the
parent
in owning a child makes a copy of its
page tables marking all the pages all
the shared pages read only
and then depends on copy on write
to make new copies of the pages that the
children actually touch
[Music]
so in detail
here we have at step one this clone
makes a read only copy the parent page
tables
at step two the first child takes his
first page fault trying to access one of
those but it can't access them because
the parent
hasn't actually finished initializing
the shared page tables
so this guy blocks waiting for memory
access
eventually the parent runs again and
finishes the page tables and wakes this
guy up and then it's just waiting for
the scheduler waiting for cpu
the reason that the parent blocked and
didn't finish the page tables back here
is that after it spawned three children
there were only four cpus and there were
five threads running it turned out that
the scheduler had the parent thread stop
and only restarted it when when the
children stopped waiting to
get access to the page tables so this
guy finally finishes the page tables
this guy finally runs and then it does a
whole bunch of initialization rights and
takes 60 page faults in a row
doing all those copy on writes and only
then out of the end does it start
running the real part of the child task
maybe the
few hundred microseconds here doesn't
matter but now at least we understand
what's going on and we can decide
whether to do something about it or not
for instance by allocating a bunch of
memory for the children ahead of time
that they if you go between parent and
child lots of times that the children
can use pre-initialized memory
so it's a summary about waiting for
memory waiting for memory can come from
all the memories allocated
it can come from trying to do a large
contiguous allocation in a badly
fragmented memory it can come from just
paging to death or it can come from
other threads that are manipulating page
tables and temporarily locking them out
except that the temporary is much longer
than you might have thought in your head
so that's for memory
for disk
it's a little
a couple of sample programs the first
one reads a 40 megabyte file
takes 680 milliseconds
second program reads the same file takes
330 milliseconds almost twice as long
the question of course is why why the
slow one if we look at a trace of these
two
this first program opens the file
does a single 40 megabyte read
and then blocks waiting for that to
finish and then during this whole
680 milliseconds
is using no cpu time and then at the end
it gets an interrupt saying oh the
read's done and then it finishes doing
what it's doing with that and closes the
file
the second program opens the file and
does
10 240 4k reads
the first read takes a while and then
this program keeps getting oh this read
finishes finished he gets the interrupt
it starts the next read that blocks
that read finished etc and uses up a
huge amount of cpu time and twice as
long
if we look at detail of those reads
what we see on the different cpu cores
is the uh interrupt handler for the disk
the hard interrupt handler the software
interrupt handler software panel wakes
up our read
my read
happens in this little bit of user code
it does a read for the next 4k and that
blocks
that's the scheduler switching to the
idle task
and then when we get the interrupt from
the disk and wake this guy up again
this little bit here is finishing the
reed that started back here
and then the user code goes around the
loop it starts another read that doesn't
finish until way up here and this
repetition rate's about 150 microseconds
uh the blocks coming off this particular
slow disc they're coming every 66
microseconds so we're missing um
every other revolution
even in the the presence of
disc hardware and microcode that's
reading ahead and buffering up things
and there's just a lot of turnaround
time between the cpu saying go read and
getting all the way out to the disc
where it just says oh i have a block
it's in my on drive
dram buffer lamp here but that still
takes many microseconds to go through
that path
so if we are waiting for discs
it's a fairly short summary the discs
are all busy or you're doing
inappropriate small transfers
or
for instance you're going off to a disc
that has a right buffer and it's in the
middle the microcode inside the disc is
in the middle of emptying that right
buffer and what it's buffered up are
rights to a bunch of different places on
the disk
and emptying the right buffer involves
12 seeks at about 10 milliseconds each
and suddenly you've lost 120
milliseconds before the microcode will
look at your read
this happens all the time the effect
that
our data center people told us when i
worked at google is
when you're doing rights everything gets
slower
it's not true that the rights themselves
are slow it's true that you get this
interference or for ssds for flash
memories
when you're erasing flash blocks the
eraser cycle takes about 10 milliseconds
and if the micro code or the hardware
and the controller for the ssd is off
erasing flash bots nobody else can do
anything
uh you can't read or you can't write
so those are the kinds of things that
that uh it's hard to see
but you can really see that you're
waiting and get some clue of why you're
waiting and then there's usual complex
interactions
seeing the interrupt activity
is what tells you
what you're waiting on and how long you
were waiting on it
in detail
so do network
here we have
12 network remote procedure calls
so this is
sitting on the client doing the cost a
client does a call
and sometime later the response comes
back from the server somewhere else
client does another call the response
comes back does a call response comes
back about three times late it takes
about three times longer before the
response comes back
and these are normally all the same sort
of transactions and should all be about
the same speed so we want to know why
those are slow
this is a little messy slide but we'll
go through it the
client program is running on cpu0
and what i want to highlight is here's a
right of
the beginning of
that transaction here's the right that's
sending away over the network the
request for that transaction here's the
right that's going over the network for
that one and there's rights for each of
them and they line up in time near the
beginning of each transaction there's a
little code that executes before you get
to the right
if you look at these three writes in
detail
one fast one and two slow ones we can
see what's really going on here's the
fast one here's the right on cpu zero
here's the packets crossing the wire
20 microseconds later there's actually
three packets here it's a 4k right it
turns out
and in ku trace by time stamp right at
the neck here's where the packets are
given to the network hardware and for
packets coming in again at the neck
inside of the tcp or udp code or
whatever a time stamp here's where the
packet came in
the second right the right is here but
the packets aren't hitting the wire
until
600 microseconds later and the third one
they don't hit the wires with 300
microseconds later
what's going on is over here on cpu one
there's a totally different program
running and it just started at this
point a megabyte right over the network
pack it packet pack a packet and the
things that this delay in these guys is
my 4k worth of packets are getting
queued up behind packets going out from
the megabyte right and when the megabyte
right finishes things go back to normal
so that's the level of detail that lets
you see which hardware resource might be
overloaded and why you might be waiting
and it turns out network delays there's
lots of sources network delays and the
thing you fix is different for each
source
uh it could be when you
send in this case a packet
there's delays in the outbound kernel
code the tcp code is off doing something
else or
has some unusual path that you weren't
expecting that takes a long time
or
the network itself can be busy on the
outbound side or there can be in the
hardware and network hardware path uh
you know with lots of switching uh racks
between
lots of machines and something like a
data center that can be slow
when you get to the other end
the machine receiving the packet
it turns out most network cards hold off
interrupts saying i have stuff they may
dma the data into a kernel buffer but
hold off interrupts in order
not to generate so many interrupts per
second that it overloads the cpu just
doing interrupt handling
so it might be 20 microseconds
before the interrupt is actually
delivered saying these packets arrived
and again
on the receiving end the kernel code may
be delayed it may the tcp code may be
off doing other things or whatever
it's also possible on receiving and the
user code that you're sending this
information to is actually
hasn't gotten to the point where it's
doing its read or
receive message or whatever to get the
data that is off doing something else
and it simply hasn't asked for the data
which boom went all the way across
and in each of these cases the thing you
fix is on this machine or on that
machine in the user code and the kernel
code and the hardware
it's important
and seeing where the packets actually go
across the wire is enough to help me
distinguish which case it is and
therefore what to go fix
so that's
that's my summary on waiting for
networks
and we have waiting for locks this is
the fifth of the waiting things
one question so do you have any and the
possibility to see like two machines
like in the same time and stuff
yes okay yes
right um
you run ku trace on two machines
the time stamps are all mapped in
post-processing to the
uh get time of day
the user visible
wall clock time right something common
right so and so you get get time of day
on machine a you've got to get time with
a machine d
you have packets going between them you
can you can then correlate where the
delays are now the get time of day on
the two machines won't be the same
[Music]
they may differ by
20 milliseconds they may differ by 120
milliseconds they will differ from hour
to hour
some people build really expensive fancy
hardware and they use
measured wire lengths from gps receivers
and stuff to try to try to reach the
point where all the machines in a room
have the same get time of day
and i find that's just sort of a waste
of effort and money
because if you send a packet here
and it arrives at some other machine a
while later
if you can identify which packet it is
on both ends
you can
for the things that aren't delayed and
there should be a lot of things that
aren't delayed
and only a few things that have that
have interference in some form for the
things that aren't delayed you can
actually line up
in time
what the good time of day offset has to
be between those machines and come
within a microsecond or so
and that's good enough to understand all
the correlations
you can calibrate right kind of on this
yeah and so when i teach uh
courses from from this uh material which
i've done four times now over the last
four years but one of the exercises in
the third week is the students write the
program that correlates the time on the
two machines so they know that you can
do it in software and that it's trivial
and i hope that those students then
don't end up in companies that think
they have to go buy expensive hardware
so does that answer your question
yes yes it does yes okay good so i'm
going to waiting for locks i'm not
coming for a very expensive hardware so
[Music]
yeah
uh
so here's uh three threads
two of them the top one and the bottom
one are waiting a long time for a lot uh
this is only you know 20 microseconds or
so but they're waiting a long time
milliseconds we'll get back to that a
second and this middle one has the lock
uses it has a lock user has lodges it
doesn't have it here the question is
what's going on and why are these guys
never getting the lock
so here's the ku trace of what's going
on
the dotted lines up here are this thread
is waiting to get the lock and it keeps
waiting to keep spinning even though
it's not running it's running it's not
running it's running it's not getting
the line the same thing at the bottom
and this middle thread has the lock
solid pink line
and when it frees the lock
part of the mechanism for freeing the
lock says oh there are there are threads
waiting to get the lock
go to the operating system futex call
and it does the wake ups of the other
threads
unfortunately what's going on
in this particular trace is this guy
does the wake ups
before these other threads wake up
our middle guy
bam goes and gets blocked again
bam goes and gets the lock again
this goes on for 84 milliseconds
so this thread has captured the lock and
it's starving out all the other threads
and the flaw is when you free up a lock
you have to not go get it again
and wait long enough for the other
threads to get a chance
so how come the other threads don't uh
don't start up sooner and and jump right
in
because here's the
wake up
and it's a good couple microseconds
micro second half later before
on this other cpu this thread actually
starts running it's waiting for a cpu in
here
and that's just the hardware delay of
the cross
core
either processor interrupts saying go
run the scheduler here there might be
work for you
and so
if you wake stuff up and you don't wait
some small number of microseconds uh
these guys can get starved out for a
long time
and then eventually by fluke
you know somewhere in here there's a
like a timer interrupt that slows this
guy down just long enough that these
others get a chance to get in before
and then one of the other other threads
will get the lock and then hold it and
starve out everybody else for a while
so
for locks
if you're waiting on locks a lot it's of
course the other threads that are
holding the lock
that need to get fixed not not your
program that's running slowly
and in order to
deal with that you have to know
first that there are other threads
holding the lock and that's what the
problem is but second you have to go
figure out which threads those are
and go fix them
um when i was working at google five
years ago i did a search overall the
source pool you know it's a search
company a whole start school searchable
i searched for uh declarations of
software lock so there were 135 000 of
them
and we had
we spent months sometimes we didn't have
at the time a good way to figure out
which lock it was
because the blocks were actually
dealt with through libraries and the
libraries used we used the same memory
addresses for data structures
for the locking mechanism so that you
could at the time you you
went to get a lock and kind of get it
you get the address of what the lock
data structure was but it was always the
same address or the same
always one of 20 independent of what the
real walk was so tracking back to the
like the line number of the declaration
of the lock that was the problem
uh took us forever
[Music]
but so
this is another example of when you're
running slowly the thing to fix is not
the thing that's running slowly
somewhere else
so it's important to design in being
able to see lock acquire and hold and
release and to be able to figure out
which log
so that's the seven things that can make
stuff run slowly
executing too much code executing
the same code but more slowly or not
executing waiting for one of the five
shared resources
[Music]
being able to see what every cpu core is
doing every nanosecond is what makes the
invisible visible
and as an industry we have very poor
tools for doing that
so i'm hoping that some of the students
who look at this think about
in their
after they finish their theses
in their work lives to go out and
implement things like this so you really
fancy what's going on it will save it
pays for itself really quickly
i made the occasional changes after
being able to see what was happening at
google that saved uh 10 years of my
salary
[Music]
can you give some clues about how okay
trace is able to do all this magic i
mean it seems it seems to need no cpu
thread it seems to
need no cash
uh and and somehow it's able to to to
give you all this output
but without changing uh you know branch
predictions and stuff
yeah well the
the the patches in the linux kernel um
take about 40 cpu cycles to record one
entry
um because the entry is just 20 bits of
timestamp uh reading the uh
the rdtsc clock in uh intel chips or the
uh
system time clock and clocking arm chips
i've
got this running on a raspberry pi 4
also
and there's 12 bits of which event and
that's all that's written
and
those
four byte
aligned values are written into
per cpu core memory blocks so there's no
thrashing of the cache between recording
on different cpus and then periodically
a block gets filled up and
there's a little time spent allocating
the next block that involves an actual
lock between the
ku trace
on different cores
and then everything else is done in
post-processing turning the raw traces
into
events with with time of day time stamps
turning those into time spans instead of
edges turning the time spans into a json
text file and turning that into html oh
yeah right so so the
so
but in detail uh you should go read
chapters 15 and 16 that explain how this
is done
basic
how much uh
code is there i i mean it doesn't seem
to have any branches it just
it just knows which 32 businesses
yeah well there's one branch in the code
that says is tracing turned on
and and you know almost all the time
tracing is not turned on
and so that branches is perfectly well
predicted
and then when tracing is turned on um
after the first time on each floor then
it's perfectly well predicted that oh
schracing's on
there's a few other tests
uh incrementing the pointer in each cpu
block of where the next thing goes i
test whether it's reached its limit yet
for that lock
so there's a test there but there's
uh
8 000 entries per block
so that test is also well predicted no
it's we're not at the end we're not at
the end not again and then one time out
of eight thousand yards
and there's uh
one other test in the
allocating new blocks to say have we
filled up the trace buffer and the user
did not ask it to wrap around you know
flight recorder mode that has to stop
when it fills we test that we're at the
end and say okay stop that's it
[Music]
preallocated kernel memory i'm just
writing it into regular memory uh
writing into my okay thanks mom
uh the only thing that's fast enough to
record this stuff
i'm literally getting uh
on average
uh a new event a new transition between
using kernel mode every five
microseconds yeah this was my question
what's the bandwidth of the of the data
sort of in say bits per second or
megabits that's my question kind of what
is the total bandwidth out of the core
or say
per system what is it
sure it's 200 000 events per second was
the
maximum we saw at google in production
live data centers during the busiest
hour of the day
to so about one minute
so if i could finish
so at 200 000 events per second at four
bytes each
that's 800k
per cpu core per second if you have 20
cores
that's uh
16 megabytes per second
okay if you uh have 20 cores and you're
in a large data center kind of
environment you have a few hundred
gigabytes of ram
and so one percent of that ram you've
got
enough room to record for a minute or
two
at full rate across all the cores
if you have a raspberry pi controlling a
thermostat or something
still with one percent of the cpu and
one percent of the ram
you can record uh meaningful traces
okay yeah
the key is that each event is only four
bytes right competing things like f
trace each event is 48 bytes
and and the bandwidth is too high and
the amount of ram it takes is too high
and the amount of time you can afford to
record contiguously is too low
so let me do a few references there's
the book there's the mansion code at the
addison wesley website which
due to uh
mediocre branding is called informati
but the code is now also on github under
dicksite's ku trace
if there any students are looking at
this who have access to the spec
benchmarks i would love to get together
and trace the spec benchmarks
the uh spec 2017 or whatever is current
and see which ones are measuring what
they claim to be measuring and which
ones aren't
and that's it
so any other questions
12 bits seems like magic
no no no you don't
understand this is just an engineering
talk
this is very carefully engineered i
counted cycles for every bit of the code
that records one entry
and
i
you know i did the back of the envelope
bad with bandwidth calculation up front
and the overhead in my budget
at
an event every five microseconds my
budget for being no more than one
percent overhead is 50 nanoseconds
to record an entry
that's shorter than a cache missed
timeout the main memory
so that says by
you know just by first principles
an entry has to take less than the cash
line in fact has to take a lot less than
the catch line
so the only reasonable choices were 4
bytes per entry or 8 bytes per entry
nothing else would be fast enough
so i chose 4. i actually ended up
packing
pairs of call return
into an eight byte entry
because uh one of my cohorts at google
long ago lost bureau
who wrote a bunch of the initial
linux
tcp stack
he said you know it would be really
helpful when there's a system call to
get a little bit of information about
what the arguments or return value are
so by packing
a contiguous call returned pair
into one eight byte entry uh
that freed up enough room not to have
two complete time stamps but one
complete time stamp and then just a
delta time in a byte and that freed up
two bytes where i could record
the low bits of the first argument to a
system call which were often useful like
which
i o devices being read or written
and another byte was left for the return
value from the system call in particular
it was just big enough to hold all of
the error standard linux error codes
including the one that says there was no
error
and if things don't fit because the
delta time is too big or the term value
is too big then we take a separate eight
byte entry for the call wasting half of
it and an 8-bit entry for the return
wasting half of it but that only happens
about six percent of the time
the other 94 they pair up and in fact
when i started pairing them up it got
faster
because i didn't have to allocate
another another entry i just overwrote
the unused bytes in one entry i was
surprised that they got a little bit
faster
so if the
if you're using the system on a
quote modern machine which has uh
speculative execution at multiple levels
and multiple uh
speculative threads um
does it make things much much more
complicated
no
um you know so thread does a system call
you're going to spend a lot of time in
the the
operating system software and hardware
doing that that switch from user mode to
kernel mode
and saving registers and getting ready
to the point where sometimes somewhere
inside the operating system you can
finally do a call to a c routine instead
of to assembly language
i just patch in at that point do my 40
cycles worth of stuff and get out okay
the operating system costs are very
costly so so stuffing for a cyclist is
not that much critical but
in particular
um
because i i go off and
separately measure what my overhead
really is and i put in the little
diagonal white lines you can see where
my
when you zoom way in on any of these you
can see where my overhead is starting to
be
the same order of magnitude as the the
real code
span flame span
and if it's not the same order of
magnitude then uh you don't i don't care
do you have yo it took careful
engineering
do you have have simulation tools that
you can that you that you can run all
this stuff but on a simulator
instead of unreal hardware
uh no
simulators are way too predictable
right
so you need
cows from the hardware
i i assume that people have like x86 or
arm simulators that include simulating
all of the
kernel code instructions
and that
[Music]
if you if you had an
arm linux kernel and you ran it on a
simulator that included my patches it
would run
yeah yeah but from simulator
from simulator you will never have that
sort of real life disturbance as which
you need and you want to see the
simulators are usually not simulating
bus contentions or whatever it is right
i mean they they
run the code and there are some of them
but they are very slow so
i mean what i'm looking at is is you
know interference between multiple
cpu cores interacting touching the same
data and stuff and
i don't know of simulators that do that
really well as you say
yeah no i i i know a simulator is slower
but but
i'm doing research i i have time to look
at stuff uh
if something is really confusing uh and
but i i i get you know i i've got my my
hypothetical mix computer which uh which
doesn't exist in real hardware but i can
simulate it not i'm sitting here trying
to imagine uh uh
watching ku trace on on my simulator
uh
yeah so does
the mix have an operating system have uh
kernel code and user code
uh
there's something called endnix that i
never wrote
uh but but somebody in japan has done
that but
but but
they're basically kernel mode i mean
there's
uh the the machine
has one bit
where you're in the kernel or
or not then you're actually you have
access you know you know to
lots more memory and so on
yeah so i think
i would enjoy someone porting the
patches to do that i think it would be
straightforward
yeah
i've been looking at porting uh patches
to a risk 5 machine but unfortunately
i've found that there's no there's no
decent time base yeah
really the board
the board they gave me has a
microsecond counter
time counter which isn't good when
you're
in a microsecond dude 1200 instructions
how hard it takes
how hard it takes 400 400 cycles to read
it
are you able to port it to an alpha
um
i i could there's no uh
no commercial value in doing that
i'm really interested in helping people
fix real performance problems in real
code that they're running today in time
constrained environments
because of course risk wave has the
this cycle counter which is very
assuming the cpu runs the same clock so
that's it's it's useless useless
i have one of these i've been using
the cycle counter stops when the
when a particular cpu is idle
and so even if you started out with all
the cycle counters synchronized across
all the forts you use which you can't
start out with but if you could they
would immediately get desynchronized
and if you have different time stamps on
different cpu cores there's no way to
to line up
you know this guy woke up that guy
because there's no there's no common
time base i see i didn't i wasn't aware
i knew the counter exists but but i
never look at the such a granularity
that i mean usually these countries run
have option to run either always or stop
sometimes but it doesn't
that's my experience has been that
there's lots of chip designers who put
in speculatively put in oh this would be
a wonderful feature to have and people
could use it to see what's going on
but nobody actually uses it and when i
go to use it what i find out is they're
useless
they've spent a bunch of hardware on
something that that's that's no good
it's a problem sad to say
i
have a
sig arc blog a couple of articles in the
january cigar blog
about the performance the four
performance counters i'd like to see
all
to be read in one cycle on each cpu
that's all you need that's all i need
here in fact
one of the problems with kutrace for x86
is is
to do the uh
instructions for cycle i have to read
the number of instructions retired in
order to read that i have to at the
beginning of traceco set up a bunch of
global state to tell the hardware
which thing to count in counter number
whatever where we've got uh a dozen
generic counters
okay
and having to do that setup on each core
because you have to change global state
in order to find out how many
instructions are retired it means that
nobody else using the machine
can use those counters
because i just took one away
and it means in particular the operating
system can't use any of those counters
and so what i'd like to see is an
instruction that says
read the cycle counter with the
guarantee that the cycle counters are
all the same across all the cores in
other words the thing you're reading is
a is a mirror of something that was set
at boot time
and the read only takes one cycle
right this whole idea of reading the
time and waiting 400 cycles to get it
means that you can't read it
more than about once every
40 microseconds without a huge overhead
and you don't know when 40 microseconds
have elapsed if you can't read the time
that's a catch-22 i believe yeah
yeah so i gave up on that and um
sticking with x86 and arm
so dick i don't know
can you see i'm holding up a book
yeah
okay so i i gave a keynote talk at ifip
congress in 1989
uh
that was you know like
30 some years ago and uh
and that
and i decided that i would
since hilbert had
had given a famous address once at a at
an international congress a
mathematician saying what problems
should people work on i i gave a
challenge problem and my challenge
problem was uh to inve to investigate
one second of computer time
yes and here's what i said uh make a
thorough analysis of everything your
computer does during one second the
computer will execute several hundred
thousand instructions i'd like you to
study them all
uh the time when you conduct this
experiment should be chosen randomly you
might program the computer itself to use
the number generator to decide what
second should be captured
uh and so on uh
uh but then you you know there were
issues about uh uh
you don't have access to the source code
and so on but anyway i i i just wanted
to say that i i consider that nate that
probably you have solved this challenge
problem at last
yes i have
thank you
is there a two dollar check
356 cents yes
and now computer surrounds millions
times faster than you wrote it
maybe we should uh stop on that note i
was going to say it's i think we've
reached the point where inflation is
going to cause
problems um any case thanks dick very
much it was a great talk uh i think uh
i i think i think it's an important
piece of work
and one which we're uh
we're going to be appreciating more and
more as the uh decade proceeds
so thank you very much for the work
you've done and uh for uh participating
and thank everybody for listening
all right and thank you for the
invitation you all take care